We have claimed that normal
random variables are very
important, and therefore we
would like to be able to
calculate probabilities
associated with them.
For example, given a normal
random variable, what is the
probability that it takes
a value less than 5?
Unfortunately, there are no
closed form expressions that
can help us with this.
In particular, the CDF, the
Cumulative Distribution
Function of normal random
variables, is not given in
closed form.
But fortunately, we do have
tables for the standard normal
random variable.
These tables, which take the
form shown here, give us the
following information.
If we have a normal random
variable, which is a standard
normal, they tell us the values
of the cumulative
distribution function for
different values of little y.
In terms of a picture, if this
is the PDF of a standard
normal and I give you a value
little y, I'm interested in
the corresponding value of
the CDF, which is the
area under the curve.
Well, that value, the area under
this curve, is exactly
what this table is
giving to us.
And there's a shorthand notation
for referring to the
CDF of the standard normal,
which is just phi of y.
Let us see how we
use this table.
Suppose we're interested
in phi of 0.
Which is the probability that
our standard normal takes a
value less than or equal to 0?
Well, by symmetry since the PDF
is symmetric around 0, we
know that this probability
should be 0.5.
Let's see what the
table tells us.
0 corresponds to this entry,
which is indeed 0.5.
Let us look up the probability
that our standard normal takes
a value less than,
let's say, 1.16.
How do we find this
information?
1 is here.
And 1.1 is here.
1.1, and then we have a 6 in the
next decimal place, which
leads us to this entry.
And so this value is 0.8770.
Similarly, we can calculate
the probability that the
normal is less than 2.9.
How do we look up this
information?
2.9 is here.
We do not have another decimal
digit, so we're looking at
this column.
And we obtain this value,
which is 0.9981.
And by looking at this number
we can actually tell that a
standard normal random variable
has extremely low
probability of being
bigger than 2.9.
Now notice that the table
specifies phi of y for y being
non-negative.
What if we wish to calculate the
value, for example, of phi
of minus 2?
In terms of a picture, this
is a standard normal.
Here is minus 2.
And we wish to calculate
this probability.
There's nothing in the table
that gives us this probability
directly, but we can
argue as follows.
The normal PDF is symmetric.
So if we look at 2, then this
probability here, which is phi
of minus 2, is the same
as that probability
here, of that tail.
What is the probability
of that tail?
It's 1, which is the overall
area under the curve, minus
the area under the curve when
you go up to the value of 2.
So this quantity is going to be
the same as phi of minus 2.
And this one we can now
get from the tables.
It's 1 minus--
let us see, 2 is here.
It's 1 minus 0.9772.
The standard normal table
gives us probabilities
associated with a standard
normal random variable.
What if we're dealing with a
normal random variable that
has a mean and a variance that
are different from those of
the standard normal?
What can we do?
Well, there's a general trick
that you can do to a random
variable, which is
the following.
Let us define a new random
variable Y in this fashion.
Y measures how far away is
X from the mean value.
But because we divide by sigma,
the standard deviation,
it measures this distance
in standard deviations.
So if Y is equal to 3 it means
that X is 3 standard
deviations away from the mean.
In general, Y measures how many
deviations away from the
mean are you.
What properties does this
random variable have?
The expected value of Y is
going to be equal to 0,
because we have X and we're
subtracting the mean of X. So
the expected value of this
term is equal to 0.
How about the variance of Y?
Whenever we multiply a random
variable by a constant, the
variance gets multiplied by the
square of that constant.
So we get this expression.
But the variance of X
is sigma squared.
So this is equal to 1.
So starting from X, we have
obtained a closely related
random variable Y that has the
property that it has 0 mean
and unit variance.
If it also happens that X is a
normal random variable, then Y
is going to be a standard
normal random variable.
So we have managed to relate
X to a standard
normal random variable.
And perhaps you can rewrite this
expression in this form,
X equals to mu plus
sigma Y where Y is
now a standard normal.
So, instead of doing
calculations having to do with
X, we can try to calculate in
terms of Y. And for Y we do
have available tables.
Let us look at an example
of how this is done.
The way to calculate
probabilities associated with
general normal random variables
is to take the event
whose probability we want
calculated and express it in
terms of standard normal
random variables.
And then use the standard
normal tables.
Let us see how this is done
in terms of an example.
Suppose that X is normal with
mean 6 and variance 4, so that
the standard deviation
sigma is equal to 2.
And suppose that we want to
calculate the probability that
X lies between 2 and 8.
Here's how we can proceed.
This event is the same as the
event that X minus 6 takes a
value between 2 minus
6 and 8 minus 6.
This event is the same as the
original event we were
interested in.
We can also divide both sides
of this inequality by the
standard deviation.
And the event of interest
has now been
expressed in this form.
But at this point we recognize
that this is of the form X
minus mu over sigma.
So this random variable
here is a standard
normal random variable.
So the probability that X lies
between 2 and 8 is the same as
the probability that a standard
normal random
variable, call it Y, falls
between these numbers minus 4
divided by 2, that's minus 2.
Then Y less than 1.
And now we can use the standard
normal tables to
calculate this probability.
We have here 1 and here
we have minus 2.
And we want to find the
probability that our standard
normal falls inside
this range.
This is the probability that
it is less than 1.
But we need to subtract the
probability of that tail so
that we're left just with
this intermediate area.
So this is the probability that
Y is less than 1 minus
the probability that Y
is less than minus 2.
And finally, as we discussed
earlier, the probability that
Y is less than minus 2, this
is 1 minus the probability
that Y is less than
or equal to 2.
And now we can go to the normal
tables, identify the
values that we're interested in,
the probability that Y is
less than 1, the probability
that Y is less than 2, and
plug these in.
And this gives us the
desired probability.
Again, the key step is to take
the event of interest and by
subtracting the mean and
dividing by the standard
deviation express that same
event in an equivalent form,
but which now involves
a standard
normal random variable.
And then finally, use the
standard normal tables.